okay we must have done good
okay welcome to overtime here are the
questions uh okay for the panel while
some Republicans are public in their
disdain for Trump others argue he's
still an influential King maker what do
you think well JD Vance right he just
got the he won in Ohio he's going to be
the Republican nominee for congress he's
the hillbilly eligible elegy guy
okay but that was his book anyway Trump
endorsed him it was supposed to be a
test right of Trump's kingmaker power so
is that a test of his kingdom absolutely
it's a stunning victory for Trump I mean
it Vance is not doing very well
um he had you know those Republican
primary voters especially in Ohio they
love Trump and Vance had called Trump uh
he compared him to heroin compared him
to Hitler uh compared him to cancer
other than that he loved the guy
that's when Trump was first running and
now all of a sudden and they literally
asked him he said well what changed your
mind he said because Trump was so tough
on corruption
I swear to God and he didn't even laugh
so it's but it is it shows you that this
is Trump's party and he will seek the
nomination and he will win it he's going
to be the Republican nominee and the
Democrats can get their act together
right yeah you're really convinced of
that 100 oh me too I've been [ __ ] I've
been saying it before the first one he's
uh first of all he's conceded this
election
he hasn't Conceited the Wonder he lost
all right
this is not a man who gives up things
gracefully look at his hair
[Laughter]
he is no he is going he's definitely the
number he's definitely going to run and
they can't deny him right that try to
deny him that nomination now you know
listen I guess I'm I'm wacky but I like
to think that somebody else can steal
that nomination I don't know how in the
hell it would I can't I mean the one
they talk about is DeSantis
I mean his his I guess strategy is I'm
Trump without being this crazy man with
the clown makeup
uh
but they want the crazy man with the
clown makeup I mean he's he's the star I
mean you know you're just not gonna
unteat him until he he you cannot break
up with a narcissist
he breaks up with you yeah maybe he will
maybe he will we don't think he will
break up you don't think over the next
two years he'll decide you know I like
Mar-A-Lago he's gonna spend more time
with his family yeah you know no
narcissist says turn the camera off and
and it's like if life doesn't change
when he becomes president he doesn't
work I mean it's like oh I'll have to go
back to that grind of being up at 11 A.M
he came down at 11 A.M
shut up
he was up at six because we know from
the Tweet he didn't come down to 11.
what's he doing his hair
[Applause]
it's all about winning he's winning
winning he did not like not winning and
he's going to do it again and he's I if
I had to bet my own money yeah I would
bet he's going to win what if he had to
bet your own life since you don't value
life very much
necessarily precious thank you
especially when it hasn't started yet
okay uh you've been vocal in your
support for American-made products how
can lawmakers better promote an
environment for business to manufacture
their products here well listen make
better [ __ ] well that yeah
[Applause]
I do think there is room in in the tax
code in look we gave it away to China we
just said yeah we'll pay dirt for dirt
and and there you go and now we're stuck
with all these you know these delays and
receiving things and all of that bar
just stuck out in Long Beach California
I just think that we have the capability
not only to make things here but to
maybe not make things in countries where
there's slavery and genocide
I think that would be a good idea
and I think slavery anywhere in China is
slavery everywhere in China because if
you've got some Industries relying on
slave labor then everything kind of
Falls to that level you're that's going
to be an interesting uh moment when the
people go to Walmart and they can't buy
things from China
since about 98 of what's in Walmart is
from China and that's why there's those
products are so cheap so that's going to
make your people very popular well
listen I I do think there are other
countries you can do business with that
aren't killing their own I just do but
really what percentage of what's in
Walmart is from China 98 you're right
okay
Bill we allowed that to happen we gave
up all that manufacturing to other
places because they make a pair of jeans
for nine dollars that's why because
people want nine Dollar Jeans but they
do they make it at nine dollars because
they don't pay their people to I
understand but so hit the people
shopping there wow ashamed of our own
slaves I'm just saying
if you're going to be honest start the
discussion to the people you're
convincing to do this by saying you're
going to be paying a lot more for
everything you've ever bought well and
therefore maybe you don't have 900 pairs
of jeans in your closet and you only
have 899.
tell that to them to the people who have
three pair of jeans in there well look I
I understand that go ahead what's the
other way federal government buy stuff
not just consumers and our president has
said I'm gonna buy American I'm gonna
make sure when the federal government
buys up people going to Walmart they buy
whatever they want they're free citizens
but the government spending American
taxpayers money because of Biden is now
going to have to buy stuff made in
America which means some of those
manufacturers are going to have to on
Shore it's going to take a long time
right but that's a good place to start I
don't want to take away consumers rights
to buy something but the federal
government buys by the way every single
weapon by law must be made in America we
don't Outsource that to China China can
make it cheaper we don't know allow it
because it affects our national security
I see that expanded Beyond just weaponry
and I think Biden was going to do a good
job
[Applause]
you know Mexicans are coming here to
take our jobs and then we find out that
you know Americans don't do those jobs
white people don't do yard work in this
country
so no one's taking the job that you
wouldn't do anyway John McCain said it I
don't know I do my own yard work so what
you don't pick fruit
no I do not pick fruit right
and you wouldn't but I'm Hispanic so I'd
fit right in I guess
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I don't know who's going to get canceled
or why but I'm sure someone's going to
try it
it's the world we live in yeah yeah that
doesn't even have to make sense
Chloe you passed a new green deal I mean
a green New Deal for Maine with support
from the AFL-CIO the first time the
Union ever endorsed a green New Deal how
did you do that
well it all started with relationships
so much of like what we were talking
about before the bill came out of my
conversations with constituents I rarely
heard my folks talk about climate change
but we talked about ice fishing every
winter and having enough rain for our
farms in the summer and having good
sustainable jobs in rural places so from
day one I worked with the unions and we
created a piece of legislation that was
really geared towards green jobs
and and people really Embrace that even
because usually what we hear is
you know if it doesn't affect you
directly and you have much more
immediate concerns that's something that
people say oh that's a rich man's
concern
[Music]
does impact rural folks directly we just
have a different language for talking
about it and especially when it comes to
job opportunity and economic growth in
rural places we desperately need more of
that especially for young folks and
that's really what the bill was targeted
at okay time to go thank you very much
everybody appreciate it